it feels so good to be back this is
season three of the divers ceo
the only difference with this season is
it's our last
season from now on the divers ceo will
run continuously without seasons
we're gonna record one episode every
week minimum
released every week on monday morning
this podcast started a couple of years
ago when i was the 25 year old ceo of
one of the uk's largest and most
exciting companies
we'd grown from just two people to 700
people i was young i was insecure i was
naive i was
single horny curious and living an
intense
unique life at an age where nothing
could have prepared me for it
at an age where i was trying to figure
out my own this podcast was about my
diary
and my pursuit to figuring myself out
and understanding the world
as i went and like you i just wanted to
live a better life
i wanted happiness i wanted love i
wanted success
but i figured out that you can't live a
better life until you know what a better
life
is what that actually means what it
looks like
you can't achieve happiness love and
success if you don't understand what
those things
are or what they aren't or if they're
even real
and so here we are this is an unfiltered
honest
rare part of the internet where i share
my diary with you and i ask some of the
world's most interesting people
to come here and share theirs too and
the stuff they share
is the things they don't usually share
the truth the stuff you can
really relate to i'm not gonna let
people sit with me here
in my new studio in london i hope you
like it if they're gonna [ __ ] you
if they're gonna give you that typical
pr manufactured
nonsense that they usually give you my
job is to take you deep when we look
into my diary
and when i have guests here to take you
deep when we look into theirs
but if you've listened to this podcast
before i'm sure you already know the
score
so without further ado i'm stephen
barlow and this is the diver ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
i just quit my job i was the ceo and
founder of social chain as a lot of you
will know and social chain is one of the
most remarkable
exciting fast-growing social media
companies in the world i genuinely
believe that
there's no company in my opinion better
at social media and doing what social
chain does
than social chain and i'm gone now so i
can be impartial about that
i started the company at 21 years old
from a desk in manchester
the company is now a huge global you
know
beast with 700 team members hundreds of
millions in annual yearly revenue it's
listed on the stock exchange
and it's doing better than it's ever
done before
that company made me everything i am it
made me a millionaire
it really positively challenged me for
seven years of my life it made me better
it made me cry
laughed scared dream it made me happy
and then i quit and when i told the
world i'd quit
people understandably just couldn't
understand
why would you leave a company that's
doing better than it's ever done before
has a brighter future than it's ever had
before you must have been kicked out
they presumed
you must have some grand plan they
hypothesized
you must be stupid they asserted
nope my relationship with the board in
the company is better than it's ever
been it's
great i have no grand plan
maybe i'm stupid here's the thing at 16
years old i stopped going to school
because i didn't think school would give
me
what i needed it to in order for me to
become who i wanted to become and
ultimately i was kicked out of school
near the end
at 18 i dropped out of university after
just one lecture with absolutely no plan
at 20 i left my first startup completely
out of the blue
again with absolutely no plan and now at
27
i left my successful global business my
job my salary
and everything that comes with it with
absolutely no plan
madness right so much is written in
personal development books and the
internet about the courage it takes
to start a new job to start a new
relationship to start a new business or
to start a new passion not enough
it's written about the equally important
equally courageous
equally confounding thing you usually or
nearly always have to do
before you start something new which is
quitting the last thing
i've just spent the last month out in
the costa rican jungle with monkeys
literally living with monkeys writing my
book and the characteristics required to
quit are somewhat analogous to the way
that i saw those monkeys
swinging through the jungle every single
morning you can't grab hold of your next
branch
until you have the conviction required
to let go of your last
those horseshit yet very popular cliches
that tell you quitting is for losers
or that you must never give up as you
see it plastered all over instagram
don't help anyone they trap you in a
toxic
narrative that quitting is a weakness an
easy way out
or worse yet that quitting is failure
quitting like starting is a real skill
and it will turn out in all of your
lives as it's turned out in mind that
quitting is for winners a large part of
the reason i've been successful the
reason
i'm the happiest person i honestly know
and the reason i've avoided
overstaying my welcome in toxic soul
destroying relationships and situations
is because i have a solid mental almost
subconscious framework for quitting if
you have a quitting framework of your
own
you like me can quit in peace without
the anxiety the worry or wasting years
of your life
consumed in wishful thinking that things
might change when you know they won't
i don't quit because things are hard in
fact the difficulty of a challenge often
correlates to the rewards on offer so
difficulty for me in my life has been a
sign that i should keep going
that i'm in a growth moment that i'm
going in the right direction and so i
live
in search of increasingly harder
challenges i often say that my
professional mission
is to fill my life with excruciatingly
hard but
definitely worthwhile challenges
challenges i know
are worth the sacrifice and i tend to
believe that if you do hard things now
you'll have an easy life later if you do
easy things now conversely
you'll have a hard life later and so
i've lived my life as you can probably
tell if you look at the
the way that i've made my decisions
seeking chaos
it turns out that's my happiness and i
avoid stability
it turns out that's my chaos but
i do quit because things suck and at the
point that a situation sucks for me for
whatever reason
right and many situations start well and
then turn out sucking
and i no longer believe that i can stop
the situation sucking or
because the effort required to stop the
situation sucking
is no longer worth the rewards i believe
that are on offer
then i quit and that is the crux of my
quitting framework
for me i'm totally deeply
in love with this company it gave me all
my friends
pretty much all my friends but for what
i wanted out of my life
at this moment for what i intrinsically
deeply
want from my life to feel the way that i
need to feel every single day
i felt like the direction i want to go
in wasn't the same direction that social
chain could take me in
i didn't think social chain could give
me it and that sucked
and so i quit and i quit with a few
reminiscent
solitary tears i sat on my laptop that
day and cried because
as i looked back over the last six seven
years right back to the days where i was
shoplifting chicago town pizzas to view
myself where i was at war with my mother
because i dropped out of university and
i was struggling to keep a roof over my
head
i was grateful i was so grateful for the
people that had believed in me for the
memories i have and for the lessons i've
learned and the journey
to every corner stage and boardroom in
the world that this business has taken
me
as a famous hip-hop philosopher once
said it was
all a dream despite the tears
and what they might make you believe
about that moment i quit with total
faith that this moment
was the right moment the right moment
for me to move on
i quit in total peace and i quit guided
by
the clear direction of my own internal
voice a voice that has served me well my
whole life
when i've allowed it to speak
uninfluenced by what society or my mom
or any other external force
expects of me without the need for a
plan
and here we are happy peaceful
and unemployed there is
a [ __ ] pandemic outside and can you
think of a time in our lives where any
of us have experienced
this much compounding uncertainty right
now we don't even know when we're going
to get our lives back we don't know when
we can plan our weddings when we can
socialize with big groups of our friends
and for some of us those worse affected
we don't know when we're going to be
able to pay the bills
return to work or find new work in some
cases your ability to handle
uncertainty will quite literally define
the quality of your entire life that's
what my life
has taught me the older i've gotten the
more blatantly obvious this has become
if you're trapped in a job you hate or
in a relationship that drains you or
you're stuck in a place that depresses
you the certain misery of your current
situation
should never be considered a better
option than the uncertainty you'll
encounter
if you go in search of more of better
of happier never ever accept
misery because it's comfortable or
because it's familiar or because it
feels
safe never i don't care how people
pleasing your situation might be
i don't care how proud it might make
your mother i don't care
whose [ __ ] feelings are gonna get
hurt if you decide you want more
i don't care if it's gonna be really
really hard for you
i don't care if it's hard in the short
term that doesn't matter more
like i said you have to do the hard [ __ ]
now to have an easier life later
if you do the easier stuff now you're
choosing
choosing a hard life later and i know
the feeling
trapped by comfort and dying a slow
death as humans we're hardwired to panic
in uncertain situations it's a an
unfortunate consequence of our innate
survival orientated programming studies
show that
studies show that the less information
you have on a decision or a way forward
the more the limbic part of your brain
takes over
and that's the part that you don't want
taken over that's the part where your
emotions live
where anxiety and fear are generated
uncertainty will make you anxious it can
paralyze you
into inaction this neurological
disposition which
you know which hasn't evolved out of us
unfortunately and as part of our wiring
was
really really handy tens of thousands of
years ago when we were cavemen and women
straying into unfamiliar territories at
night when we had
little information about what laid
around the corner because back then
being fearful in uncertain situations
ensured our survival but today
these mechanisms aren't helpful in the
context of the world we live in and the
decisions we have to make every single
day
it has been clinically proven that the
most successful people in the world are
able to override that innate
mechanism and shift their thinking to a
more rational place they're able to use
a logical framework not irrational
emotions
in times of great uncertainty where life
demands you to make decisions without
all the evidence which is most life
which is every day
and if you want to be more successful
happier and find better love you too
need that logical framework for dealing
with uncertainty
overthinking and the procrastination it
creates stem
primarily in my experience from trying
to make perfect decisions
in a world where perfect decisions only
live in hindsight i had the pleasure
when i was in brazil of meeting barack
obama and he's one of my one of my idols
and a
just i think a political legend and he
said
you don't have to get to 100 certainty
when you're you make your big decisions
you can just get to 51 and when you get
to 51
make the decision and be at peace that
you made the decision based on
the evidence that you had available to
you at that time
51 is enough it's enough to be at peace
100
doesn't exist if you can make more
decisions at 51
you'll get feedback faster on the
outcome of that decision you'll
therefore learn faster
and therefore you'll progress faster and
the opposite is true
if you wait for a hundred percent you'll
make decisions
slow you'll lose time you'll lose the
chance to learn and you'll lose the
opportunity
a lot of the time and the truth is as i
said 100 doesn't exist
51 percent certainty has to be enough
for peace
100 doesn't exist think of uncertainty
as the gap between the miserable current
situation you find yourself in and the
unknown happy situation you want to get
to it's a place you have to travel
through
time and time and time again in all
areas of your life if you want
fulfillment if you want love and you
want to be more successful
it's the it's the most vulnerable place
on earth
because the lights are off there's no
sat nav and the destination is unknown
there's usually
an untrustworthy blueprint however when
you've reached the end of
your quitting framework whatever your
framework might be and it's clear that
your current situation sucks and that
you're not gonna be able to change that
or it's not worth
changing it and that your life is
leading you towards inevitable
unhappiness
you have no choice but to embrace the
fact
that uncertainty is the only way out and
that the certain misery of your current
situation will never
be a better option than the uncertainty
you'll encounter as you search for more
as you search for better and as you
search for happier
when successful people tell you how they
got successful they never seem to
mention luck
because if they tell you the role luck
played in their success it seemingly
takes something away from them it
it takes the intention out of their
genius it takes the correctness from
their brilliance it takes a sense of
purposeful wisdom from their story and
it replaces it with
the truth and the truth is that luck
played a huge role in their success but
luck if they talk about luck it isn't as
easy to sell [ __ ] to you
complicated and intentional sells well
if it's intentional i can
teach it to you if it's complicated i
can charge you for it
you're not going to buy their course
follow their page or go to their seminar
if they talk too much about luck but the
truth is
luck timing a good fortune player a huge
role in every entrepreneur's success
so when i'm talking about my success i
have to start there i
was lucky i started a social media
business at the perfect time a time when
social media was this
wave coming into shore and i just
happened to be surfing that day
but there was a lot of other people
surfing that day and some of them had
fancier surfboards and some of them had
more experience surfing and
some of them had richer parents but they
didn't get here
and so as wonderful as it is to admit
for my ego
there was intention there was skill
there was hard work and there was talent
involved
so let me just talk about some of those
things let me start with skill
in chess you become the best in the
world by mastering that one skill
however in our careers and our lives in
our entrepreneurship journeys
things are much more multifaceted and
complex and layered
they're almost never defined by mastery
of just one skill they're defined by our
ability
to be pretty good at a bunch of uniquely
complementary skills and this is what
they call
skill stacking complementary but unique
skills are incredibly
important let me explain what i mean
steve jobs the company he created apple
i'm sure
you all know apple right he's a great
example of exactly this at the heart of
jobs
skill stack is a passion for design be
it fonts packaging architecture
steve jobs spoke about how one
calligraphy class he took at reed
college
contributed to his success a class he
wasn't going to take he said
if he had never dropped into that one
single course in college the mac which
we
probably have all used would never have
had the beautiful typefaces that had
multiple typefaces proportionately
spaced fonts
this one rare skill and the wider design
skills which none of his competitors had
would ultimately set apple and steve
apart in a way that would revolutionize
his entire industry and ultimately your
life my life and the world
he was never the best in the world at
design or calligraphy but he developed
that keen
understanding of the winning design
principles and by combining those skills
with
his unique deep insights about people
and what they want and his tech
knowledge
and his rare strategic mind and his
salesmanship and his leadership skills
and his
business skills he was able to build a
company that focused on advancing
technology through beautiful design
that's the unique complementary bit that
made him different that company felt
different
better it felt more valuable because
steve's skill stack was different better
and ultimately more valuable to the end
consumer
jobs wasn't the best in the world any of
the skills within a skill stack
but the complementary and unique nature
of his skill stack made his company the
best in the world
and made him undeniably the best in his
industry
for me the skills that set me apart as
an entrepreneur first and foremost my
social media
skills and then that was help on my
public speaking skills my general common
sense
my people skills that allowed me to
think and predict the future and how
people would behave
and then my sales skills which
underpinned all of that and allowed me
to go on stage or go on facebook or
linkedin or instagram or twitter
and sell those ideas to the world there
isn't any other social media ceos in
this country that were able to build an
audience for themselves of millions and
millions of people
using their social media skills and then
with my ability to go and speak on the
world's biggest stages and sell
eloquently and envision
what the future would or wouldn't look
like with conviction
i was then able to make my voice heard
above all of the others using social
media
and when you have the loudest most
persuasive voice and a high level of
technical knowledge
not the best in the world but high level
in an industry which is largely driven
by the power of authority
sales social proofing personal branding
and opinion
you'll quickly rise to the top as i did
my industry
valued that unique skill stack and so
people like me and
of course garyvee a friend of mine who
share a very similar skill stack
both rose to the top of the social media
marketing industry in our respective
countries even though
neither of us are admittedly the best in
the world to any one skill
we're not the best public speakers in
the world there's better people like i
know better people
at public speaking than me we're not the
best sales people in the world i know
better salesmen we're not the best
entrepreneurs in the world i know
better entrepreneurs if i'm being
completely honest with you but we don't
need
to be and that's the point being you
know good at five unique and
complementary skills will take you
much further in your life than mastering
one in your life in your career or in
your business you have to ask yourself
that question
what are the unique complementary skills
the unique complementary and rare skills
that would allow me to rise above the
rest
and instead of mastering the [ __ ] you're
already good at which a lot of people
tend to do
go out and work on those things to me
that's the
secret next i feel like i've got to
mention hard work
you know there's been a lot said
negatively and positively sometimes
about hard work over the last five years
you know
and i know that if i post on my social
channels right now telling you
that hard work will help you become
successful someone's going to call me a
prick
because linking hard work to success
apparently
also unintentionally links laziness to a
lack of success
and that makes people feel like [ __ ] so
they hate it
and i'm not one of those you know toxic
hustle porn stars that's gonna try and
encourage you to
stay up all night and reject your family
and you know not feed your kid and
sacrifice your mental health to build a
business
you know i think i basically tried that
and it was a really [ __ ] bad idea if
i'm honest
i had to make drastic changes in my life
to save myself
i got to 23 24 years old and i realized
how empty miserable and pointless my
life would be
if i sacrificed everything for money
success and status and when
then when i got there i had no one no
family no partner to enjoy it with
all of those material things would mean
nothing if i
over-invested in them and under-invested
in the people i would enjoy those things
with in the future
a stupid a common and a regrettable
mistake that you should
at all costs avoid making but
i would also be lying to your face if i
told you that hard work doesn't matter
if i just spent the last seven eight
years of my life working tirelessly to
get where i am today
and i told you otherwise i would also be
dishonest
and that's also a prick thing to do as
far as i'm concerned hard work does
matter it undeniably
increases your chances of success but if
it costs you your mental health
if it's dumb hard work well you're not
actually working because you're
burnt out unmotivated and tired then it
does absolutely nothing but waste your
time
then you should just sleep or go on
holiday or walk your dog or
see a nan you know nobody can tell you
the balance
that's your job right no no instagram
hustle porn star can tell you how hard
or
soft you should be working so you have
to listen to yourself not to
nocturnal instagram hustle porn stars
but the number of hours you smartly
keyword
invest in your future the greater and
probably the sooner you'll reap the
rewards i overworked
everyone i knew and it came at a great
cost to my happiness at one point i have
to admit
i looked around and there wasn't many
people left and i could have arguably
got
probably got here without such an
obsessive relentless sacrifice who knows
if you know where i came from you'll
probably understand
why i was too desperate to take the risk
but yeah hard work mad
hard smart work and and let me
let me say one last thing
talent there's a lot of myths
surrounding the concept of talent and i
don't really buy into the talent myth
as much as many people do everything
that seemed to
really make a difference to my success
was
in some ways a skill right i saw what i
had to sharpen over a series of years or
decades all my lifetime
you know i'm not smart you know like
these book smart kids in school that i
knew you know i
i'm not school smart i'm not grade smart
my spelling is [ __ ] you know if you've
seen
my posts online you've probably seen
spelling mistakes my maths isn't great
i'm not
a natural genius if those even exist and
the only thing i can point at and say
yeah that thing there really helped is
my unshakable
natural sense of self-belief but even
but even that isn't a talent because i
know
if i'm being honest with myself if i was
brought up in a different household in a
different time in a different country
i could quite easily not have believed
in myself
but that self-belief is this in my life
it's been this formidable tailwind that
has pushed me forward
through my entire life right self-belief
is the crowbar you need to
crack open new skills i remember the
first time i i spoke on stage when i
must have been what 14 years old and i
was shaking
and this speech that i was meant to
deliver was quivering in the harm
in the palms of my clammy hands and
you fast forward 10 years and i'm
speaking in brazil in front of tens of
thousands of people
alongside barack obama despite despite
the evidence to say that i wasn't
capable back then
some something somewhere inside me
believed
that i could and that belief got me
through it got me through
every piece of evidence that tried to
tell me otherwise
it got me through all of the hard stages
it got me into into
boardrooms it got me into a life that i
love
and then a life that on paper i didn't
have the qualifications or the right
to be living so that's my talent real
unnegotiable self belief but yeah
if i'm honest a lot of it was luck
fortune and good timing
but then i'm not trying to sell you [ __ ]
but my book is coming out soon happy
sexy millionaire you can get it now on
pre-order on amazon but
yeah luck i recently hit 1 million
followers on instagram and i did one of
those corny posts thanking my followers
for their support
it wasn't one of those number one helium
balloons with
with a glass of champagne or prosecco it
was just a quick instagram story
thanking the team
that had worked with me over the years
to get me there and following that post
i received
hundreds of direct messages from other
creators from some of you
from followers from friends from even
from uh some distant
family asking for tips on growing their
instagram channels in the same way and
whenever i'm asked for tips on how i've
achieved anything in my life my brain
probably does what your brain does i i
mentally like
rummage around looking for some kind of
easy secret or hack or
or cheat or or something that i can
share that will be actionable and
and simple and people gravitate towards
easy
because easy sells it sounds much better
than hard right and much more
than patient and much better than real
in sales and marketing if you can
create the perception that something is
easy and it will yield high returns
it'll sell like hotcakes because
we all want a small investment to
produce large returns
this is why most of the clickbait
headlines you see in most of the
get-rich-quick schemes you see
plastered all over social media and the
internet often have a headline that will
try to convince you that you'll get a
big return
for little effort you know you've seen
the ones six pack abs in
seven minutes or how i made a million in
30 days
on one end of that sentence you have a
big return a big
prize and on the other end you have a
relatively easy
investment asked to view in order to get
that big prize
the truth is it is simple
but it's also really [ __ ] hard
astonishingly and this blows my mind but
it proves the point and i think a very
succinct way
in the first 800 posts i did on
instagram i got 10
000 followers in the next 800 posts i
did on instagram
i got an additional 1 million followers
in fact i got 200 000 followers from
just the last
10 posts that i did and if you look at
that graph
it starts slow and then it goes fast and
that's
exactly what consistency looks like in
the real world the results are slow
invisible and then fast and visible
consistency
the small things the small seemingly
insignificant things
are compounding for or against you in
every aspect of your life
right now your teeth if you don't brush
them today no different slow
invisible if you don't brush them for a
year you're going to be screaming in a
dental chair as the dentist rips them
out at the end
and the end will be fast and it will be
visible and it will be painful in this
case
and this is the power of consistency
compounding for or against you it's
happening right now in all areas of your
life and you don't even know or see it
happening but it's definitely happening
i was consistent on instagram posting
almost every single day for years
even when i didn't feel like it and when
i posted i looked at the analytics i
learnt right and then i used that new
information that learning to conduct an
experiment
to try something new and then after my
experiment i looked at the analytics
again i learned and
repeated the cycle slowly slowly
invisibly
getting better and that is the great
thing about consistency it means that
you get to continually try
learn fail sometimes and slowly and
visibly improve
so you can start [ __ ] at something like
i did but with consistency
you're consistently learning tweaking
and making marginal gains and after five
years of that invisible
improvement you'll go from being pretty
bad at something to pretty damn good
consistency is the simple hard answer
to pretty much everything you want to do
it's really that simple
the older i've gotten and the further
i've traveled in the business world the
more
glaringly obvious it's become to me that
the key difference between
the people in my life that are the most
fulfilled the most romantically
prosperous the most successful and
on the other hand the most unhappy
people the most romantically ineffective
the most
broke is their willingness
and their ability to take responsibility
for their lives
you know human beings are just experts
at taking responsibility for great
things that happen to them you become a
millionaire
yeah that was me i'm self-made you write
a great book yep
all my ideas you win a bet yeah i knew
that was gonna happen
but when life delivers misfortune when
it delivers failure when it delivers
hardship for many
taking responsibility becomes an
impossible task you know who wants to
take responsibility for not making rent
for getting fired for gaining weight for
failing their driving test like i did
the first time
for being dumped nobody because
admittance of fault admittance of
failure or admittance of weakness or
inexperience or naivety
turns an uncomfortable mirror on
yourself in a way that a fragile ego
or a delicate self-esteem can't always
bear
you may remember i had a guy on this
podcast called near iel and he was the
author of a book indistractable which
tried to teach all of us how to spend
more time doing the things we want to do
and he pointed out to me and taught me
really that we're not pleasure
seeking humans we're actually discomfort
avoiding humans and you know so turning
that mirror on yourself and taking
responsibility
for many is just too uncomfortable to
bear from a psychological perspective
and you can see it all over social media
you can probably see it in your own
friendships you might even see it in
your own relationships
or unfortunately within your own family
people who default to blame
and it's been evident in my career that
responsibility is a
remarkable remarkable life hack and
the older i've gotten the more cognizant
i've become of how i deal with taking my
responsibilities
because you know i'm i'm just as flawed
as everybody else sometimes i like to
blame [ __ ]
sometimes i don't like it to be my fault
even when it is you know relationships
you're having a bad day
having an argument with your girlfriend
or something like that and you know
you're wrong but you don't want to admit
you're wrong because your ego showed up
that day
and instead of saying you know tom
pissed me off
right what i've tried to do is mentally
and consciously refrain that sentence to
i pissed myself off because of tom and
suddenly when you do that it makes it my
responsibility
but in doing so it gives me back control
and therefore it allows me to do
something about the mood i'm in
right if i go around saying tom pissed
me off it's tom's fault it's tom's
responsibility he did it and i was just
you know this puppet who's being
emotionally manipulated by the
unpredictable rollercoaster that is life
i have no control in that scenario when
i
mitigate and give up my responsibility
and therefore what is the point
in me trying to do something to change
the situation or improve my
circumstances i am helpless
you know if i tweeted this someone would
probably try and counsel me they'd
definitely call me a prick again
taking responsibility has become
selectively
controversial which is so bizarre and
seemingly political
i say selectively controversial because
we all agree that some people in our
society
should be held responsible for their
actions criminals who are in jail
for murder but we dare not apply that
same standard
of personal responsibility to someone
that is clinically obese ever
never regardless never someone who's
been
fired from their job ever [ __ ] boss
[ __ ] company
or someone who's gone bankrupt oh
unfortunate they can take no
responsibility for that
that is something i disagree with of
course there's important nuance in
all of these examples right a rich
person's
efforts aren't necessarily to the causal
factor of their
wealthy lofty inherited wealth and a
poor person's efforts conversely aren't
necessarily to blame for being poor
but equally that doesn't necessarily
mean that either party
shouldn't take responsibility for the
situation they find themselves in
regardless and this is a controversial
idea
right it's a political one for some
reason radical responsibility is for the
brave
for those that value progress over ego
and for those that care more about the
future they want
than the present they have and i i can't
tell you enough if you are someone who
has great ambitions and wants to be
happy and wants to be fulfilled
and wants to live a life on your terms
you have to take hold of your life
you have to take hold of your potential
you have to take hold
of your responsibilities who
wants an unpopular opinion about the
virus absolutely no one
right if you haven't noticed there's a
deadly virus
raging through our population it's real
it's killing people it's tragic it's
awful
but and here's where i might be canceled
again
not that i've been cancelled before but
i think probably in the course of this
conversation today i've probably been
canceled maybe at least once i don't
know what the [ __ ] we're doing with all
this locking everybody up business
um i understood the lockdown originally
and it makes sense when it's in context
of a plan but this
locking everyone up indefinitely and
destroying the economy strategy i think
is deceptive i think the government are
lying to all of us
what exactly are we waiting for
logically what
what is it we're waiting for and when
i've when i've reasoned this and gone
over this
multiple times with multiple friends
even on twitter i did a poll on twitter
asking the world this question what is
it we're waiting for and i provided four
options
i actually only can think of three
options right option number one
is for the virus to magically disappear
option number two is for a vaccine and
option number three
is for herd immunity and if we go back
to option number one which is
the virus is going to magically
disappear
how how how
viruses don't magically disappear and
when you think about the world we live
in
locking everyone down in this country
but allowing people to fly
in and out constantly and fly all over
the world right
means that there's no point locking this
country down the only conceivable way
that i think we could get the virus to
magically disappear all at once
is if you lock down the entire world all
at the same time for about 30 days
right because there's gonna be a little
bit of spreading between families and
households that will keep the virus
alive
but i can't see outside of a global
orchestrated lockdown how option one the
virus will magically disappear is a
a useful or a possible uh optional
solution so let's move on to option two
option two is a vaccine
right and i think when i did the poll on
twitter and i asked people what we're
waiting for what they think we're
waiting for this was the most popular
answer it was a vaccine but here's the
problem the world health organization
who are in charge
of you know advising countries and
advising us on the strategy that we
should adopt have said
that you can't wait for a vaccine
because a vaccine isn't guaranteed
and if you look at every coronavirus
that has ever come before
sars for example there is still no
vaccine and that virus is 18 years old
so waiting for a vaccine is against
history and it's against
the advice of the world health
organization so i think
we should also rule that one out right
and then you have option three
herd immunity the approach that bojo
boris johnson our prime minister here in
the uk
slipped up on tv and told us he was
aiming for when he said that maybe we
could just take it on the chin or words
to that effect
and since then because of the public
backlash he quickly
reverted from that position and never
mentioned the word hurt immunity or
taking on the chin ever again
but when you look at the the strategy
and you look at the options we have that
is what we're doing
that is what we're doing we're opting
for the herd immunity approach
and maybe i'm not certain my own opinion
here maybe
it is our only option maybe it is but
maybe
our politicians and our government are
too spineless to tell you that
that's what i believe i can't see
another option
can't be the vaccine it's not going to
vanish so what are we doing here
and what i want from our political
leaders is i want a bit of honesty
regardless of the social backlash that's
what leadership
is you lead you don't follow
i think our government are lying to us
the more you see the world's problems in
a binary way
police versus people black versus white
or left
versus right men versus women or poor
versus rich
the less effective your solutions will
be to solving those problems
the world we live in now has become more
polarized and binary than
ever before social media and broadcast
media have
completely obliterated the chance for
nuance for
healthy debate and for respectful
disagreement
and social media and its unrelenting
commitment to virtue signaling
ultimately forces you through threat of
digital
punishment or cancelled culture to pick
a side
and to defend that side and all of its
predetermined pre-packaged world views
unquestionably
like an enslaved sheep like as enslaved
brain-dead
sheep and if you dare to disagree
on even one of your side's sacred
views then that means you're one of them
and if you're one of them
you must believe and carry all of the
beliefs
labels and predetermined views that they
carry and therefore be treated as such
in 2020 thinking for yourself is
controversial it's dangerous
it's not worthwhile because speaking
objectively might just cost you your job
it might cost you your family it might
cost you your life and most of us don't
even know that we've lost our ability to
think and speak for ourselves because
the influence
of the crowd and the influence of our
side and the virtue signaling that comes
with it
is so [ __ ] strong and tempting but
but when you think about it the truth is
that if everyone around you agrees with
your views all of your views
then they're probably not your views
anyway over the last six months we've
had some of the most crazy times i've
experienced in my short life in our
society we've had
the black lives matter movement we've
had this global protest all around the
world and we've had
political warfare on top of a pandemic
the single most
powerful content that i've produced in
that time the most valuable ideas i've
shared were ideas that were brave enough
to disagree
even when it was seemingly unpopular to
do so and even when i faced the
likelihood of being cancelled or losing
a client because i shared those ideas
you can't solve complicated nuanced
problems with
simple binary narrow solutions and the
compulsion to view
complicated things as simple and binary
will ruin
all parts of your life you see it in
everyday life you see this obsession
with binary
all around us you know you start dating
a guy
and your mum calls you and she says is
it love
that's a complicated almost undefinable
thing right
love right the way you feel about
someone but your mum's binary question
forces a simple yes or no answer which
probably doesn't exist
a better question one that allowed for
nuance and appreciated the complexity of
the situation
would have probably gone like how do you
feel about him
right that allows for nuance it
appreciates complexity and until we can
bring nuance respect and appreciation of
complexity to our conversations
online in our workplaces in our homes
and our whatsapp groups
we will never find answers we definitely
won't agree upon the solutions
and we'll keep asking the wrong
questions because i've
shared some things on my social media
channels over the last couple of months
which
are somewhat um unpopular
let's say some people leap to the
conclusion
that i disagree with the movement or the
idea or the underlying cause or the
you know the just reasoning behind it ah
you know i don't i'm black
i i [ __ ] hate racism i felt it just
just like many of you have
but when this all began i was honestly
horrified by the binary narrow-minded
narrative that played out online
you know trying to shame people into
posting on social media about racism or
black lives matter or the george floyd
incident is not fair or helpful it's a
unfortunate consequence of the
virtue signaling narrow cult-like
polarized
world that we live in and if someone
doesn't choose to post on social media
that doesn't mean that they don't care
and it doesn't make them a bad or evil
person think about it we all watch the
same
horrific video of a black man being
asphyxiated to death by a white police
officer who had his knee on his neck for
nine minutes
right as he pled for his life and asked
for his mother
it touched every empathetic human being
deeply
on an emotional way on planet earth
trust me however
we will all naturally deal with what we
watch in a completely different way
of course because we're all different
right we all know different things and
we all respond in different ways
that's an expectation that we have
everybody around us in normal life but
suddenly in these moments we demand
conformity
everyone must believe and do what i've
done or they are evil
what a stupid way to think some people
took to social media immediately
some people spoke to their friends
privately some people listened and tried
to learn
some people were so overwhelmed and
confused that they couldn't find the
words
and the truth is we don't need everyone
to talk
especially when everyone doesn't know
what they're talking about but we do
need everyone to listen
think about it public social media posts
aren't the only way people process how
they're feeling in fact when you think
about it public social media posts are
actually quite a bizarre
unnatural way to protest intense genuine
personal and complicated emotions
people that post less aren't more racist
that's a stupid naive way to think maybe
they're just less tempted by virtue
signaling maybe
let's remember the goal here the
fundamental goal isn't to
trend on social media or to be
politically correct or for our followers
to think that we are
a great kind and full of virtue it isn't
to humiliate anyone who disagrees or
doesn't understand the goal
is change and people who are genuine
about the issue know that that's the
goal
and i'm i'm going to be black forever
and my kids they're going to be black
forever when they're born
and so all i really care about isn't all
this noise and virtue signaling and
fighting and whether this person's
kneeled or not all i care about is
change
and there are many important pathways to
change one
is self-reflection and we saw a lot of
that one is political pressure we saw a
lot of that one is protesting we saw a
lot of that one is educating yourself
and we saw
a lot of that any quick and easy action
like social media posts and
instagram stories that endeavor to solve
such a complex and systemic issue are
probably not going to be a meaningful
and effective action right we can all
admit that
i'm not saying they don't help i'm
saying it's not going to solve a
systemic issue
so if someone's first reaction wasn't a
tweet or an instagram story
maybe they were thinking a little deeper
having the ability to even
consider nuance to consider complex
impartial thoughts
and to be less narrow with our
perspective is a superpower in 2020
in this crazy polarized digital world
where we so
desperately need more virtue and way
less
signaling i beg you to stop attacking
anyone that doesn't perfectly conform to
the set of beliefs
that your cult espouse you shouldn't
unfollow them if they believe something
you don't you know a lot of people
on my linkedin especially chose to
unfollow me because of my post about
black lives matter
the the the smart thing to do the
intellectual thing to do the thing
that's conducive with progress is to
respectfully engage
and to engage to understand not to win
not to convert not to humiliate
i beg you i beg you to think for
yourself
as i go on the journey of trying to
think for myself a little bit more
to have clear and consistent values
but loosely held broad-minded beliefs
and i know for a fact and this is this
is something which i don't think anybody
can deny
that if if we could all apply this
approach this standard
to society's pressing problems we would
have less pressing problems if we were
able to understand
someone in their world and where they're
coming from we would live in a better
world and if we approach
our opponents with a sense of love there
would be less evil
and that that's the world that i want to
live in
that's the world that i'm fighting for
you know racism scares me
but not for the reasons that you might
expect there's something about racism
which people don't talk enough about i
think
which i think is holding people back i'm
not scared of the prejudice i'm not
scared of the discrimination
i'm scared of how the conversation about
race and inequality
will make young black people feel about
their future
i think the conversation although it's
helpful and although racism is very very
real
also stands a chance of convincing young
black people that they have
lost before they've begun and this isn't
just true about racism
it's true of all forms of discrimination
across all of the world and it's
intrinsically linked to this idea of
labeling if you label
somebody if you label a young black man
as a failure or a disadvantage they
according to the science and psychology
and research may just start to believe
that
and young people who are part of
minorities or underserved groups will
start to live their life believing
that they have a disadvantage and in
some ways living that disadvantage it's
why
i've spoke so much about the importance
of having that internal locus of control
about taking responsibility and when you
when you're brought up believing that
you live in a society where you you
start with a disadvantage
it's difficult to take responsibility
and
maybe rightly so i'm not saying racism
isn't real racism is very real
i've experienced it through all of my
life in fact i've experienced it more
the more successful i've gotten you see
it more
when you stand in that first class line
to get on the plane and someone just
cuts in front of you and then they turn
and say sorry i didn't think you were
stood in this line
but when i get on the train to london
and i'm sat in the first class carriage
and the train attendant
walks up to me after walking past
everyone else and says to me
presumptively
this is first class mate he didn't check
my ticket
he didn't check anyone else's he just
walked up to me and told me that this is
first class mate i understand
racism i know it exists i've seen it all
around me but the biggest thing
that's helped me to overcome the
inevitable
racism that lives in our society and i
do say it's inevitable because of the
way that our world is wired
i do think it's fairly inevitable i
think discrimination in many forms
is inevitable while you have such strong
influences in movies and tvs and media
and social media
the inevitability of racism has had less
of an impact on me because i've
not allowed it to i've not allowed it to
be my excuse
and i think and i worry that that is a
possibility for some people
a possibility that i quite honestly
understand it's the same with your
grades in school
getting a d or an e isn't the end of the
world but
it can be if you then live your life
believing that you are a d
that you are an e that you if you give
yourself that label
and then you start walking into job
interviews feeling like an e
or you start applying for jobs that you
think and he deserves
the label can do damage too and this is
why when i'm speaking to minorities
and all of you minorities that are
listening anyone who considers
themselves to be part of
an underprivileged group that might be
disadvantaged in some way
you can't be defined by that
disadvantage the minute you believe you
are you become defined by that
disadvantage and
that scares me of all the things in
racism in the world we live in today
that is the thing that scares me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you